Did the rules change regarding this Mandalorian
tool in the season 3 finale? Or is there
an explanation hidden in plain sight?
There have been many major battles across
"The Mandalorian" and its multiple seasons,
but few of them can match the scale and intensity
of the battle of Mandalore in the Season 3 finale
episode. As Din Djarin and Grogu have their
climactic confrontation with Moff Gideon,
so too do Din's fellow Mandalorians engage
in their own big fight to retake their home
planet once and for all. It all makes for
another epic "Star Wars" battle, aside from
one tiny problem — one part of the on-screen
skirmish doesn't really make sense to some fans.
Throughout the battle, audiences see various
characters — particularly Axe Woves and his
fellow Mandalorian fighters — using jetpacks for
traversal. This isn't anything new for the show,
as a previous episode of "The Mandalorian" also
saw characters employing jetpacks. However,
the exact manner in which this piece of gear is
used in the finale may conflict with an important
bit of information that may have been established
in the series just a few episodes prior.
During the Season 3 finale of "The Mandalorian,"
Axe Woves uses a jetpack to manually fly into
space and, later, propel himself back
to Mandalore's surface. Considering the
show's sci-fi trappings, there's not much of
an issue with that plot point — or, at least,
there wouldn't be if it didn't seem to
violate the in-universe rules that "The
Mandalorian" had set for itself
earlier in the very same season.
Back in Season 3, Episode 4 of "The Mandalorian,"
it seems to be established that jetpacks in the
"Star Wars" universe can only be used
to carry their users a relatively short
distance. If that's true, it makes sense
to add such a limitation to what would
otherwise be a pretty overpowered piece
of gear, especially as the story required
a reason that the group couldn't simply
pursue their prey with jetpacks. Granted,
it seemed like the bigger problem was
the noise that the jetpacks would make.
"The mountains are too high. If we
use jetpacks, the beast will hear."
Either way, they didn't clarify exactly
how far the jetpacks could take them if
fully fueled up. The problem for
some fans is that this seeming
limitation is tossed out the window in
the Season 3 finale. According to them,
Axe Woves shouldn't be able to take himself all
the way up into space with a "Star Wars" jetpack,
let alone still have the fuel to fly out of
the ship before it crashes to the surface.
All in all, if it is a continuity
error, it's a fairly minor one
that doesn't really affect the overall
quality of the battle or the episode.
Some diehard fans of "The Mandalorian" also took
notice of the apparent discrepancy in
the use of jetpacks during the Season
3 finale. As one Reddit user put it in
their list of issues with the episode:
"The jetpacks limitation was a pretty big
issue in a previous foundling episode,
but now someone can just hit
low orbit with no problem."
Nonetheless, one fan has pushed back on
the critique by offering a theory that
could possibly explain why the jetpacks in
the Season 3 finale seem to be so much more
powerful compared to the ones featured in
Season 3, Episode 4. The fan suggests that
there might be a difference in build quality
between the jetpacks used by the Children of
the Watch and the ones used by Axe Woves
and his fellow Mandalorians. They wrote,
"I'm thinking the Children of the Watch group
were making do with whatever they could find,
building their equipment in
a cave with a box of scraps."
By contrast, the Mandalorian resistance had access
to regular society and would naturally be able to
take advantage of better tools and equipment.
Another answer could be that they simply had
more fuel prepared for the battle in contrast to
getting taken unprepared by the raptor before they
could top off the tank. Neither theory has been
explicitly confirmed, leaving fans to make up
their own minds about whether this is a continuity
error or simply a subtle bit of storytelling.